ما عدت تسمع هذه الصرخات في هذا المستشفى
الا قليله
وعمر هذا الربيعي ساعه وهو الوحيد الذي
اطلق صرخته الاولى في هذا المستشفى اليوم
في حاله الولاده التي يستقبلها المستشفى
في تراجع مستمر منذ سنوات
كثيره قبله
30 حاله ولاده اليوميه اليوم اربع حالات
عدد كبير من المستشفيات اغلقت ابوابها
وعدد كبير من الاطباء الولاده والاطفال
اصبحوا عاطلين عن العمل
ليس اطباء توليد وحدهم
المعلمون ايضا يواجهون ايام صعبه
هذه المدرسه وسط العاصمه الصول اغلقت
ابوابها بسبب قله التلاميذ
فالارقام ترسم لكوريا الجنوبيه صوره مجتمع
مسن ينقص عدد سكانه كل عام ونسبه الخصوبه
فيه هي الاقل في العالم بعدهم كونغ بينما
يعيش معظم الناس فرادى او ضمن اسر مشكله
من زوجين ذو الاطفال
الكوريين في الاطفال الى هذا الحد
يستعدان للزواج قريبا لكن رغم ذلك
فتفكيرهما في الاطفال مؤجل ومرهون بشروط
كثيره
الاول ليس سهلا يحتاج الى تفكير ونقاش مع
زوجي الغلاء فاحش ورعايه طفل ليست بالامر
الهين
دون حاجه الى احصائيات يظهر اثر تراجع عدد
الاطفال في الشارع بوضوح
مشهد كهذا لاسره بثلاثه اطفال نادرا ما
يرى
تحولات الثقافه والاقتصاد كان لها اثر
مباشر على هرم السكان
المفارقه ان حسابات الاقتصاد ذاتها غادت
مهدده فهذه الشركات والمباني العملاقه قد
لا تجدوا من يشغلها او يشغلها في العقود
المقبله هذه حديقه اطفال في العاصمه لكنها
تكاد تخلو من الاطفال بل ان فيها من
المسلمين اكثر مما فيها من الصغار ولا
مفاجاه في ذلك خصوصا وان معظم الدراسات
تحذر من خطر وجودي يحدق بالبلد في مجتمع
لا يتكاثر بشكل الكافي محكوم بكل انواع
الازمات ولو بعد حين محمد البقالي الجزيره
سول